what was the point of looking at this
well what's nice about having done this
is that a lot of the work that we just
did is going to help us with this guy
over here so I'm gonna drop myself with
you set of axes and I'm gonna be super
ultra lazy because we already factorized
right we already factorized this is just
the reciprocal of that so all the
factors are the same so I don't need to
refactor eyes the asymptotes are quite
easy to work out or at least one of them
is you're going to have x equals zero
you told me that earlier so I'm just
gonna pop that on the intercepts are
also easy to work out have a look
because we already factorize this we
know what the numerator is going to look
like over here so what are my two
x-intercepts x equals plus or minus one
so let's check those guys on now the
last thing is regions right well luckily
for us because the factors are all the
same the regions are also the same I
mean I could redo all those lines again
but I don't need to I've already done
this right so therefore I'm gonna get
this section over here remember it
started positive here then dip down like
this then it goes up and down okay now
here comes the tricky part I know where
I'm supposed to go but I don't have as
much information now that I don't have a
horizontal asymptote and we don't have
an easy way to work this out okay so
what can we do here to work out what it
is doing at the extremities a really
really simple thing we could
differentiate right because we have
calculus now if a I are we go through
all of them for this graph over here we
didn't need any more extra information
look at this stationary points and it
turns out the point inflection you don't
really need to worry about where it is
it's there but this I don't know I don't
have a conclusive like oh this obviously
must be where it goes okay so therefore
I'm going to differentiate so if that's
why over there what rule would you use
in its current form what would you do
it's a it's a fractured right so what
rule applies to a fractured usually the
question rule would apply it right and
there is nothing wrong with using the
question rule here you call this you you
call this V and off you go
however accurate we learnt the question
will earlier this year as soon as we
learn what the question rule was you
learn a very important thing I taught
your very important thing about the
question or what was it if you don't
have to use it don't use it because it's
an awful rule to use it makes everything
worse and more complicated you can still
get the right out are obviously
sometimes you have no choice like in
this case but it's just error-prone and
it's just a very long process to go
through so is there something I could do
to this that will mean I don't have to
use the question rule okay so you can
see this as a fraction right well when
you've got fractions you can just divide
them through like if I gave you ten over
five right or let's do something super
ten excellent you wouldn't use the
question rule of this would you right
because you say I can simplify this
thing and write it not as a question you
would write it as two x to the help me
out negative one right and then you just
use power rule well I can do exactly the
same thing over here let's use this
space underneath instead of writing it
as a question I could write it as two
separate things I've got 1 over X that's
X to the power of negative 1 right and
then what's left over what else is on
the numerator it's gonna be take away
wow it's early but usually we could do x
squared divided by X right this is X ok
that's it this is a lot easier to
differentiate right no poison chain rule
anything like that required when I go to
the derivative what happens when you
differentiate X to the negative 1 tell
me what to do
power comes out the front and then I
reduce the power by 1 so that'll be a
negative 2 what happens this guy okay so
this is a bit of an awkward way to write
it I don't usually look like negative
indices I do for this why did I write
the negative
like this why don't I write as 1 over X
okay it's an early morning I get it we
need to think hard though like this is
to unit stuff this is not extension
stuff this is to unit stuff we're an
extension class we're gonna have to
manage this why did I write it in index
form when I usually hate negative
indices what was the point of it yeah
okay well okay I'm gonna get a fraction
here whatever X and I usually prefer
fractions negative indices a we'd one of
the first things we learned when we
learned negative indices in u9 is how to
get rid of them how to write them as
fractions rather than that why did I do
this
have a think what did i do on the
immediate next line this is the point we
were talking about right like why do we
what is simplify mean well simplify mean
it depends on like what you're going to
do with something right like factorizing
is sometimes simpler and sometimes it is
not sometimes expanding is simpler so
what did I do
and why did that require negative index
I'm not I'm not gonna give me out are
you guys know the answer what do we do
it's a thank you thank God okay when you
have a fraction its how to differentiate
right because we're trying to avoid this
question rule yeah we're trying to avoid
it if I have a negative power I just
used this very very simple rule okay you
can almost do it without thinking so
that looks good but I actually don't
like it like I don't need to
differentiate again so now I'm gonna get
rid of the negative index that leaves me
with this are you happy with that okay
now when we thought about this guy over
here we worked out its horizontal
its behavior at the extremities by you
we didn't write it but the way you've
thought which you actually use limits
right you looked at the limit as X
approaches infinity of this thing and
you're like oh this denominator takes
over okay when you deal with this you
don't get something useful because you
get infinity squared or infinity which
is infinity apparently which is no use
to you okay but now that I had the
derivative I've got something more
useful so let's um let's carry on over
here if I take the limit as X approaches
infinity not in my original function
but of my derivative yeah so that's why
I differentiated that limit I know what
the derivative is now I just found it a
second ago it's minus one over x squared
minus one that's what it is now this
thing is a little more useful what
happens as X approaches infinity what is
this guy yeah this this denominator gets
huge which means this minus one over
that denominator gets tiny really really
small
so therefore when I actually evaluate
the limit this will go to zero what
happens this negative one negative one
is still negative one he doesn't care
what X is it's just a constant right
minus one I should say so that's
negative one now what does this tell us
well as I approach this far end of the
graph on the right hand side what is the
gradient approaching its approaching
negative 1 what does that look like it
looks like it looks like this doesn't it
it's this line in here right or
something like I don't know where it is
but I know that's the gradient okay and
you can repeat this process in fact if
you do plus or minus infinity you get
the same thing can anyone tell me why
plus or minus infinity there are at
least two reasons you can think of for
why you can do it for it
okay so the first reason is cuz it's
squared right squaring doesn't matter
what sign you stick in there you'll get
the same value out the other way you can
think about it is that this function
here the derivative it's not just any
function right this is a special
function it has a kind of symmetry what
kind of symmetry does it happen this is
an even function isn't it cuz look it's
got an even power yeah and no other
things in there that are gonna change it
in fact this also has an even power we
just don't usually write it it's got a
zero on it zero is also an even number
so all your powers are even therefore
you have an even function so therefore
plus or minus infinity it's going to
look symmetrical does that make sense